[Music]
i'm christopher hine and today i'm going
to talk to you guys a little more about
ropa no kamae and
why it's not a weird thing at all and
it's a very very natural thing but we
kind of think of it as this special
extra weird stance or something like i i
don't know i myself speaking for myself
i have spent a lot of times
really going into the complexity of the
special way you've got to stand and and
really talking about why it's a special
stance and it's absolutely not um and
i i feel kind of dumb that it took me as
many years as it did to kind of
understand how very natural and normal
it is and why we don't need to talk
about it like it's a special crazy thing
um and i'm gonna show you how i talk
about it now uh so i'm gonna get josh
out here we're gonna go to work josh
[Music]
all right
let's talk about uh ropanokomai
and again this is part of my i'm i
really want to call ropanukamai by what
i think it's his proper name and not by
hanumi honmi is a relative position how
you relying to someone else and
ropanokomaya is how we stand in aikido
which is let's do it together so we look
cool okay so this is this thing right so
this is ropa no kamae um ropanokomai
just means six-way stance meaning you
can move in all six directions forward
backward left right up down right so you
can move in all the directions um
this is the way we stay in aikido now
look i spent a lot of time really going
like oh it's this this special precise
thing where you know if you drug your
front foot back it would hit the middle
of your back foot and you know these
things and sometimes having a hard time
explaining to people like people would
have a hard time getting the concept and
you know me talking about it and i think
it was only hard because i talked about
it in such a weirdo way right as being
weird right so look um one of the games
and i think i've shown it on this
channel if not i think it's on my my uh
youtube page because i use it all the
time which is basically the setting up
my eye um thing right and so we both
stand square and we set up my i don't
just move outside of my eye okay okay uh
so so are my
distance here right and play this game
where someone comes in and tries to
touch your shoulder right like this and
they try to get out of the way okay now
it's good because it explains why why
why are my eye is the way it is and and
lets them understand the amount of time
it takes to get out of the way and all
the stuff all right now if you let
people play it long enough what happens
is the guy trying to tag starts going
like this right and then the more they
get like that the other person wants to
start going like this now no matter how
much i tell them to stand square
they always start going into that
position because basically what they're
doing is they're going into haunt me
okay now
you might not think that at first
because you know hanumi's this special
position but if you take a step forward
you just went in on me right look it's
real simple if i take a step forward
ball of my foot's on the ground and i
rotate my foot in i just landed in on me
so it is easier for us to go forward and
backward faster if one foot is in front
of the other it just gives us an
advantage and so that's why when you're
playing this kind of game and you're
trying to go forward or go back this is
what you do right so that's why if we're
attacking someone or dealing with
someone or getting out of the way
someone we should have one foot forward
because we're faster in that plane now
if we're going sideways we're faster
with our feet like this right so if i
want to shuffle to this side or this
side my feet are faster this way so this
makes perfect sense i want to go this
way this way makes makes good sense
right
so there's nothing mysterious about it
it's really simple all ropano kamae is
is take a step forward and turn your
heel and you're now in ropanokoma it's
real simple it's just you're starting to
take a foot forward then if you turn
this foot sideways you get a little
stability going this way and you can
change to that plane so there are some
advantages to standing in specifically
that way but that is the essence of it
there's nothing radically mysterious
about it and so i find now that letting
go of talking about it like this really
special way you have to stand makes my
life a lot easier and it makes it easier
for my students to actually grasp the
concept of why they put a foot forward
instead of thinking that they've got to
stand in this special stance that does
some kind of magical thing right because
there is no magic it's just a
biomechanic makes you move better this
way and that's why you should stand that
way in these kinds of situations so i
hope that kind of shook this out a
little bit i think it was it was good
so we'll see in some future videos i'm
christopher hines joshua t my salon of
daniel's right over there
studiously
looking through that lens and trying to
capture the image that we all know she
can capture so we'll see in some future
videos thanks
[Music]
you